I'm Cooper cup and we're playing start
bins cut I'm going to be giving a
category I got to each one to star one
to fit one to cut Remember the Titans
start sure I'm benching Friant likes and
I'm cutting Rudy sorry I've got a lot of
respect for you d but I just doesn't
like those first two of my first two
favorite so I gotta go with a SuperSpeed
start I'm going to levity collect at the
bench betting super strength for my you
know why I need to do day to day I just
doesn't come into play you know it's not
what I need I'm going I'm gonna go Tiger
Woods start for Tiger to do what you did
for so long and they have to come back
to a lot of injuries to love awfully off
the court stuff if you like come back
and do it is and masters I think that
takes a lot and some that I don't think
you've seen really through sports ever
that kind of come back so go tiger start
Tom Brady then it's hard it's really
hard no I don't even know I that's why
I'm gonna go with we keep the
seven-layer dip
I'm going mean start seven-layer dip
bench and putting feet do you want to
not say wings IV wings has to be able
one I am a I'm either a honey barbecue
or above spongebob start I don't know
what written more Diaz so I'm gonna have
to cut that one and now I'm gonna go
south part o favorite spongebob episode
I think when rusty crabs are selling
pizzas I'm super tough and this to start
bench cut